all right so here we are in a two column
stance there's a line on the floor our
toes are both touching it but we are two
people wide there's a little bit of
space right here for the point of swing
through in fact you can imagine there's
a little Gulf ball right there that we
swing through during the pattern and
there's a bell hanging in between our
heads and shoulders that we swing
through um we both decide to spin the
same direction we're going to spin our
playy that way and MCE both poer like
Wheels rolling in that direction for me
this looks kind of like I'm in reverse
and for Adam when he looks at me it
looks kind of like he's forward but the
important thing that they're both going
way Adam's going to ring the bell grab
my arm and take us through to UL BL he's
like this is sweet over here I ahead and
say there yep so Adam brought me to his
side and he's happy with that but then
I'm kind of like well you know I
actually want to go backward my side my
side's pretty sweet and I'm going to
take Adam with me ring the bell see how
sweet my side is Adam and then Adam's
like yeah your side's pretty sweet but
actually I'm going to grab that arm hit
the do Ball come over here so we're
going to do that without the exra beats
in between bring Bell to my side hit the
g ball out side bring the Bel to my side
hit the g ball out side over and over
begin and that is a forb cross St and
part move now from here we practiced
where we might snag the poy from our
partner so for me I'm looking down there
when he swings to hit the when he swings
to hit the golf ball I'm watching his
hand come over mine and tracing him
touching his
hand where I can grab it and eventually
when I'm
comfortable I'm going to take it and
snag the boy turn into a weave for weave
so that I get away from Adam don't smack
him so Adam's going to steal over the
top soon as my arm starts coming up he
starts touching my hand looking for the
opening to snag and when he's ready he's
going to snag
it and he get around into a reverse
weed those are the easiest steals from
across St SCB from there we went off
into a little side J of practicing basic
basic stealing from instead of a cross
Dan position a one behind the other
person position so notice how Adam is
making penguin hands not letting his
fingers get all Sear where you can snag
in your fingers and keeping a v in
between his thumb forefinger which is
exactly where he grabs the PO he holds
his penguin's hands Palm
down looking with his peroral vision not
looking over his head one way or the
other and just stay there at the ready
and I'm going to hand a reverse spinning
poy up into his penguin hand and hand a
reverse spinning po there and then I'm
going to steal it back and steal it back
and it in and in and since he's spinning
in Reverse it's coming back over the top
towards me I take my penguin hand and
slide it in there as it comes over the
top to get a
hold that's much easier than me trying
to sort of like chase after it and grab
it that's a lot of extra
work so that's like pretty much the most
basic back front stealing pattern um
then we worked on uh stealing from a
reverse figure eight so I'm going to
take a little bit wider stance so I can
rock back and forth I'm going to give
Adam the reach around swinging up and
over and I have to commit to being able
to do a figure right there I can't just
sort of get to here and let it flop I
can't get only part way and then hit
atam I have to reach all the way around
doing a figure a Adam has T-Rex arms so
Adam has his his arms up close to his
body
and he's looking for where he can slide
that in and grab it for me go ahead and
grab it and then he's got the p and when
I see it come back I can snag it start
tracing
him gra it and so we practice that on
both sides
[Music]
so on and so forth
then we actually just went right for it
with
threey so Adam's now going to actually
do a reverse 3D weave what's important
is that Adam really really Jiggies his
body really turning his torso so that
his belly button looks all the way at
the camera all the way to the back wall
and that way I I really can see his
wrists there I really can see him over
there I know
grab so I I have to wait till the last
poy over here I'm looking at his his arm
come across the red poy there maroon poy
so I don't want to grab that orange one
I have to wait that extra moment until
the the maroon poy comes up and over the
top Adam's going to keep doing that
reverse weave motion with his hands and
now on this side I'm going to give him
the reach around and hand that back to
him so he's got another we
and I repeat the sing on this side I'm
swaying with that on I grab the last boy
cross hand over the top then I hand the
reach
what what that did we do next yes that's
what we did we did
this does that
work we went back to the Cross Dan we
because eventually we're going to
connect the across dance pattern and
that weaving skiing pattern and I I got
another poy I've got a third po but to
keep it simple I'm just hanging it out
here for now before I start spinning it
Adam's going to start out our cross
dance four
beat and since I have two PO he has a
free hand he wants to grab my PO swing I
need to be swinging this way there you
go all the blenders will be removed in
and this is where this is where we t
um yeah so those were the building
blocks and moves that we went over and
that lays the foundation to start
combining these cross stance moves with
uh behind and front weaving Steels both
forwards and reverse